vamos a resolver algunos problemas de
longitud dice alfredo dibujo una línea
de 72 centímetros en el patio con un hit
azul muy bien entonces el alfredo se
puso a dibujar en el patio de su escuela
y otra línea al dibujo otra línea con
gis rosa verdad con gis rosa que es 14
centímetros más larga que la línea azul
y nos preguntan qué tan larga es la
línea de gis rosa que pintó alfredo muy
bien así que digamos que tenemos aquí la
línea de gisa azul que pintó alfredo y
esta línea tiene una longitud de digamos
72 centímetros muy bien
ahí tenemos la línea que pintó alfredo y
nos dice el problema que también pintó
una línea con keys rosa muy bien vamos a
pintar digamos la línea con gis rosa ahí
tenemos la línea con gis rosa y nos dice
que es 14 centímetros más larga entonces
digamos que más o menos hasta esta hasta
esta longitud hasta este punto tenemos
72 centímetros muy bien y el resto son
14 centímetros verdad porque son 14
centímetros extra que pintó en esta
línea rosa con respecto a la línea azul
entonces la pregunta es cuánto mide esta
línea rosa y eso es algo muy fácil de
calcular verdad porque podremos
simplemente sumar 72 vamos a hacer un
poco más grande 72
14 verdad y si sumamos dos más cuatro
nos da 67 y 1 nos da 8 así que toda esta
línea toda esta línea tiene una longitud
de 86 centímetros muy bien entonces esta
es la respuesta vamos a ir con otro
problema dice un cable de un puente mide
33 metros otro cable es 13 metros más
largo que el primer cable cuánto miden
los cables en conjunto si los alineamos
por los extremos muy bien entonces vamos
a notar lo importante el cable mide 32
metros de largo verdad y tenemos que el
siguiente es 13 metros más largo muy
bien entonces vamos a pintar los cables
digamos que aquí tenemos un cable que
mide 33 metros de largo porque los
cables de los puentes suelen ser muy
grandes y tenemos otro cable que es 13
metros más largo muy bien entonces aquí
tenemos un cable de 33 metros digamos
hasta aquí sería 33 metros y el resto es
de 13 metros cuánto mide este cable
bueno serían 33 metros más 13 metros y
eso nos da un nos da 46 metros de
longitud que tiene este cable sin
embargo no nos preguntan eso nos dicen
cuánto miden los cables en conjunto si
los alineamos por los extremos entonces
tendremos nuestro cable de 33 metros que
x es lo pondré aquí abajo 33 metros y
vamos a alinearlos por los extremos
ahora vamos a poner aquí el otro cable
que mide 46 metros y vamos a sumarlos
verdad esta es la longitud de los cables
en conjunto ya que están alineados
cuánto miden en total bueno tendremos
que sumar
y tres metros y cuarenta y seis metros y
eso nos da un total de bueno si lo
sumamos tenemos tres más seis son nueve
son nueve y tres más cuatro son siete
así que el total es de 79 metros vamos a
hacer un último problema este dice
carlos tiene una bufanda de 36
centímetros él decide cortar parte de su
bufanda así que ahora sólo mide 19
centímetros que y vamos a hacerlo con
este color
la pregunta es cuántos centímetros corto
carlos de su bufanda así que vamos a
dibujar nuestra bufanda digamos que no
no es nuestras de carlos no sé por qué
razón pudo haber cortado la bufanda pero
ahí tenemos la bufanda de carlos muy
bien y digamos que tiene algunos listón
sheets por ahí ok tenemos esta bufanda
que además mide 36 centímetros verdad
vamos a ponerlo así esto mide 36
centímetros
6 centímetros muy bien y el detalle es
que carlos va a recortar su bufanda no
sé no sé por qué razón pero lo va a
recortar y le va a quedar una bufanda de
19 centímetros muy bien está esta
bufanda ahora mide 19 centímetros muy
bien la pregunta es cuál es la longitud
que corto carlos es decir estamos
pensando en esta sección de la bufanda
todo esto que recortó de su bufanda muy
bien entonces esto es algo muy fácil de
calcular verdad simplemente tenemos que
calcular 36 menos diecinueve verdad es
la diferencia y esto es muy fácil 36
menos 19 bueno vemos que el 6 es más
chico que el 9 entonces vamos a vamos a
va a pedirle prestada una decena verdad
entonces se va a quedar como dos decenas
y aquí vamos a tener unos seis sino 16 y
si a 16 le restamos 9 nos quedan siete y
si a dos le restamos 1 nos que
1 así que tenemos 17 centímetros verdad
17 centímetros fue lo que recortó de su
bufanda ahora bien también podrías
empezar al revés verdad podrías partir
de tus 36 centímetros y si le restamos
17 puedes hacerlo por tu propia cuenta y
vas a ver que te sobran 19 centímetros